initially when you're building a
business you're just
in the weeds you're with the team and
you're just doing
and i think as a leader of a business
it's really important to take some time
and step back and think about
what your intentions are and how you can
lead the team
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford what is it like organizing an
event for thousands of people
every year meet karina bauer ceo of imex
group
karina bauer is ceo of uk-based imx
group which organizes the two leading
global shows for the international
business events industry
imex in frankfurt held in germany each
spring and imex america taking place in
las vegas each fall
each show typically attracts 14 000
business event professionals for the
opportunity
to do business with 3400 plus
destinations venues and suppliers
from 150 plus carriers karina bauer
welcome to my show how are you today
i'm good thanks thanks for having me of
course are you in the united kingdom
right now
yeah i'm in the uk i'm in a small town
called brighton just on the
right on the south coast i love it so
you're
you're in a small town in the uk yet
you're responsible for organizing some
of the most
amazing and extraordinary events both in
frankfurt and in las vegas
uh you know i love attending these types
of events and i'm especially excited to
hear now the organizers perspective
organizing events that thousands of
people come to working with thousands of
businesses i can't imagine
those are easy you know times during the
year both in the fall and the spring
and karina you you started imex you know
18 years ago i believe right and i would
love to
to hear a little bit about you know this
how you know what sparked it and and
how you you know all the way back and
throughout your journey extract some of
those interesting lessons that you've
learned about leadership and about
you know event management and those
sorts of things absolutely well i'm not
sure if you're aware but imex is a
family business so it was actually my
father
ray who started the company and prior to
imex
he had been in the exhibition and the
business events world
for a number of years so i kind of grew
up in this world
attending trade shows attending events
and i didn't
necessarily think that that's uh what my
future would hold but
um i joined the business in 2002
just a year before we had our first
event in frankfurt
and uh i really just love the business
and i think
um you know you're either an event
person or you're not
and for me they build up to creating
a product like an amazing event with
thousands of people and
being able to really see and feel the
fruits of your work
there and feel the atmosphere of that
that was
for me i love that and enjoy those
events i mean you have 14 000 people
roaming around
you know huge halls do you actually get
a chance to breathe and examine the
beautiful work and
and take pride in it or is it only after
the fact no
you do at the time as well because
there's something really special
you know on the first morning about
seeing thousands of people come in and
then seeing them connect and
there's a real energy and the energy
i've learned over time
is the energy of people many of whom
know each other from around the world
coming together and meeting and they are
so
happy to be meeting and doing business
that that energy just
accelerates through the halls so you do
you do feel it and then of course when
you run events like that people come up
to you all day and say thank you and it
was wonderful and we've done this we've
done that business
and that really gives you a buzz as well
so you you do enjoy it it's
it's kind of that play hard work hard
culture
uh and i always say to people who are
looking to join us
you know i say if you're the type of
person who enjoyed exams at school you
probably enjoy events because it's that
same
sort of focused pressure that you have
in the lead-up
and you've either done the work on the
day or you haven't
the same as an exam right so if you
enjoy that
kind of pressure you probably enjoy
events and then of course you get to
relax afterwards
and you know think about it and go well
didn't it go well and really debrief it
and then go again
and i like that element for me that's
always worked well i've got a chance to
stop
breathe review and then and then make it
better and
that's what i've always loved that
ability to kind of do that incremental
innovation
every single year do a better job that
for me is
i guess what keeps me going i i love
that idea
and that idea of you know improving one
percent in every iteration that at the
end it just accumulates to something
to something incredible that looking
back is a huge shift but you know
with every iteration you're just you're
just improving a little bit one of the
things that
you know i love understanding about
leadership is this idea of
intentionality and
you know i read over the blog post where
you outline some of the commitments that
you have
for 2021 and and i think that that
speaks a lot about you know the
leadership style and i'd love to you
know pick your brain
you know as a leader of this great
organization or what how do you
how do you think through these decisions
and what are some of those you know big
commitments that you've made
for for 2021 yeah first of all i think
you know that word intentionality is
really important i think that's
something i've learned
over the past 20 years you know
initially when you're
building a business you're just in the
weeds you're with the team
and you're just doing and i think as a
leader of a business it's
really important to take some time and
step back
and think about what your intentions
are and how you can lead the team it's
certainly not something i did at the
beginning and if i were
going to do one thing again it would be
to really intentionally take that time
out to think
and to prepare and you know as
you said we we released at the beginning
of this year sort of a blog or two blogs
with 12 commitments for the year
and it was important for us to do that
because it really built upon
some of the key themes that we work on
year round to
drive not only our business but our
community forward because
what we do as a large event is we're
kind of the
melting pot we're coming together of our
whole global industry
so it's really important that we take
issues like diversity and inclusion
sustainability micro communities
innovation and really championing them
really for the whole community and help
our
industry to learn from what we're doing
to learn and be inspired by other people
um and and we see our role as kind of
educators as well
so if you take a subject like
sustainability and that incremental
innovation that we've talked about
previously you know we built one of the
most sustainable
trade shows in north america but we've
done that through
having a clear intention to build
a sustainable event but doing it through
small innovations baby steps we call
them
year on year and year we don't throw
away what we did the year before we just
slowly build on that and that's kind of
what we try to do in
all different aspects so diversity and
inclusion is something we're looking at
now
and we have that opportunity in our
position
to not only do that for our events but
also help our community to learn so
that's the way we do things in a very
intentional way
um you know and and we try to
to really put out the uh our learnings
as well and
show people where we've done well but
show people as well some of the mistakes
we've made
so so call me just a few of the you know
either mistakes
or you know things that you've done that
surprised you
over the years as a leader and and i
think that i usually get so inspired by
these things because
they really reflect on this idea of this
incremental progress i don't understand
why people
sometimes assume that somebody who gets
a new position will immediately be great
at it and immediately will not make any
mistakes it's all about
you know that feedback loop and
improving so where have you seen that
improvement
you know on your capacity as a leader
over the years
yeah i think uh for me personally you
know i
i became a leader very young so i was in
my early 20s and i think when you're
you're young you know you're very black
and white about
you can be very black and white about
things so over the years i've learned
that there are shades of grey
and that's been very good for me
personally because
i think it helps you to gain perspective
so the things i've learned over the
years is how to gain perspective
how to take a step back how to help
other people to learn as well so that's
also something that you learn as a
leader over time
is what you should be doing versus what
you delegate and how do you delegate how
do you
help people to develop um how do you
coach them without and how do you let go
really especially when it's your own
business right if there are a lot of
entrepreneurs
listening to this it's really easy to
have very strong ideas about what you
want um
but how you get there sometimes you have
to be more relaxed about so
i've learned a lot of those skills and i
i think i'm a better listener
today than i was even five years ago
actually
and i think also the unimportant thing
as a leader is
to uh really think about what's
important
for you personally but also what's
important for your business because
things come at you
all the time so how you prioritize how
you work out what's really essential to
yourself to the business
all these things are very important and
and it's a constant learning process i
don't think anybody
gets saying oh now i'm perfect and being
a leader you know if
you're constantly learning so i guess
that's the other thing
is being able to take criticism
and being able to be very
self-reflective when you're at the top
of a business again as an entrepreneur
you don't get that much feedback because
everybody's always
looking at you so what i've learned to
do over time is
involve myself in organizations uh so
for example i'm a member of ypo
and i can get feedback from people in
different industries that way
and just really seek out opportunities
for yourself to learn
and be self-aware of what you are good
and bad at and not
expect yourself to be good at everything
so those are the kind of things i've
learned over time you know
nobody's doing your job review if you're
the ceo of your own business
right so you have to really learn how
you're going to
get that feedback for yourself and and
move forward so i think
hopefully those things are things that
people can take away
practically and certainly over time
that's kind of
where i've sought to be and i think it's
also important to think about what you
want your culture to be
and what you want your vision and your
mission to be again those things
if you can set out um at the beginning
what's important for you with that i
think people can
follow you more easily i remember what
it's like
you know the days leading up to to any
of the events that i had the privilege
of organizing
much much smaller scale than what you're
talking about so and therefore i can
imagine that the number of
emergencies and crises that i had
is also on a much smaller scale yet they
were incredible
they were you know over the top you know
earth
earth destroying everything is going to
and nothing's going to work
yet somehow you know things end up
usually okay
what are these experiences like because
i cannot imagine you know you're talking
about listening and you're talking about
prioritizing
i can't imagine a more important time to
exercise those elements in the days
leading up to the event where you
probably have
a thousand of emergencies coming in yeah
well i think the first thing
is setting an event business like ours
is
uh we um really sought out
to work out our processes so that we
were never fire fighting the basics
that's what we called it you know like
all the basics this should be standard
so that when the emergencies come in
you've got the capacity to deal with
them so that was them
the first thing that we sought to do in
the first few years
of the business but yeah i definitely go
into
i call it like the event vortex so a few
weeks before the show
everything that's not essential to the
event gets deferred
to later and you know nowadays i can do
that for the week before the show
in the early days it was two months
before the show that nothing else got
done
so you just have to cons it's a constant
sort of
sorting of priorities and deferring
anything that isn't truly essential to
the event
um and that's important if you're a
business whereby you're judged for that
week
of that event like it has to be right
otherwise you don't have a business at
the end of it so
that's kind of how we've always looked
at it i think nowadays for us the
challenge
is um running the events in a way that's
really successful whilst also looking to
the future so that we have
all these sort of 365 projects going on
so that we can keep developing and
innovating
that's really important to me that we
can um
look to the future and not just the next
event but that's a really hard
transition to make as well
right and that makes perfect sense and
so over the years
what are some of these incremental
improvements that you've observed you're
making
not just to the events but but that's
your to the organization as a whole
because i'm imagining that every event
you conduct
you're rethinking okay was the
organizational structure correct was the
delegating the best that it was
what what are some of the key
improvements that you've noticed yeah i
think that's right i mean i
like to think about leadership and
organizational structure so i'm
constantly tinkering if you like with
that i mean one of the things that we've
been doing over the past year where we
haven't had our events
is really working hard on becoming more
agile and flexible
team and actually not having our usual
work to do
has really allowed us to almost blow up
some of the organizational structures
right
and knock down sort of walls and silos
and so really for us now it's how do we
built into our next
events that are coming at the end of the
year but not build back those walls
so we're working really hard actually at
the moment
on um creating a much more flexible
self-managed organizational structure
and that is something that you don't do
overnight you know if you've got a team
of
60 people in a structure it's not
something that you just break apart so
it's about
small experiments um small changes
um that people want to make that they
put their hand up for
not to have a job title to be more roles
based rather than
title based to be more company wide
rather than department only
so it's these kind of incremental
changes to the organization that i think
over time will have quite a big effect
as people see that and maybe put their
hand up and say actually
i'd like to work like that as well um so
i think with everything you know whether
you're sort of looking at something like
sustainability or whether you look at
organizational structure
it's about making these small changes
it's a much safer way
to drive innovation it's not always
as quick um but it depends what it is
you're trying to do in
in an existing organization i think
that's a kind of safe way to experiment
and obviously a huge upside is that
you're able to
you know independently you know get
feedback on experiments and if something
went wrong you can pretty you can much
easier isolate
what happened that that caused this you
know because you're able to compare it
to another instance where you saw that
something worked
and obviously if you do a complete
breakdown shift then it's very very hard
to pinpoint
what went well and what didn't talk to
me a little bit about the day after
the event they after you know you have
it's a very interesting
situation that you have where you're
building a product where you know
there's really two
huge touch points right with customers
per year that you're able to learn from
an iterate for the next time
so what is the how do you go about even
thinking
of what is the best way to learn from
the experiences
and to to make those incremental
improvements for the next time
yeah that's that's a really great
question because actually that is
something that we've learned to do
better and better over time
um certainly our team are taking notes
all through the event
and we're talking to our customers all
through the event so as event organizers
we're on the show floor all day every
day
going around talking to all the
customers what went right what went
wrong
what you know what can we improve and um
we spent about
three weeks after each event in each
team
debriefing and talking about the
improvements that we would want to make
we obviously have customer surveys and
nps scores
and we take all of that data as well and
then we have a big
team meeting where each team presents um
the top three things that went
right the top three things that went
didn't go right
and what they had worked on you know
sort of
reviewing the goals if you like and then
they also
have an opportunity within that
presentation to say
improvements they think could be made in
any part of the show
might be nothing related so it might be
our finance team
talking about something that the sales
team would be operating on
but they have that opportunity to say
you know this is what i saw and this is
what i observed
and this is what we thought could be
done better and then we take
all of that information in and from that
we create our okrs and our goals
for the following year's show and so
it's a process it takes us a few weeks
to do that and get through it
but that allows us it allows everybody
in the business to have a voice
which is really important um because you
know i think even the most
junior person maybe it's their first
time at the event they might have the
most
insightful feedback because they're
coming from it
totally afresh so we want to bring all
of that
into our thinking and then do our very
best to
see how can we you know some things are
big investments and
other things are changing a badge you
know i mean
it can literally but i suppose the other
thing is
for people in the organization and and
also our customers to know that
everything matters so whether it's the
font size on the badge could be better
or you need to invest in a completely
new tech platform
you know these are very different orders
of magnitude but they all count
and that way we can build out a set of
innovations that we can work over
on over the short term and medium and
long term
i can't even imagine the complexity that
goes into doing
what you're doing with with imex and you
know just from
from my personal experiences i can
appreciate you know the the complexity
and i can even appreciate i can even
more appreciate the complexity behind
the debriefing mechanism
how to actually you know end up with
with actionable insights that you're
able to
to you know to move into you know actual
improvements for the product in the next
one and i think that's fascinating
karina thank you so so much for joining
me i know how busy you are
and and i can't wait to to attend one of
these events in person once this is all
over
before we leave i have to ask the most
important question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
my three words would be um optimistic
adventurer and informal
i love it karina thank you very very
much
stay safe stay healthy and i'll see you
at an imax
uh pretty soon hopefully i very much
hope so take care thank you very much
[Music]